hi I'm Rachel Nicks and this is dylan
Palladino we're here today to try to
inspire you to get your workout on even
when it's freezing cold and snowy
outside we're going to start with single
leg stretch so go ahead and just
interlace your hands on your right shin
and then roll like a ball on your low
back keep your left leg up keeping the
shoulders up exhale switch and switch
every time you hug your knee into your
chest try to curl up a little bit higher
and really activate the core hug both
knees into your chest and then you're
going to kick out reach up overhead
exhale hug knees back into chest we're
gonna start Dylan and I by lifting that
top leg up and then lowering it right
back down then the top hip for a little
pulses then sweep to the front without
kicking me in my head hold right there
and then we have ten little pulses bring
your knees over your hips grab your
thighs lift your head neck and shoulders
and then extend your arms are to pump
your arms vigorously exhale two three
four five inhale two three four five
exhale good grab the shins lift your
elbows try to keep this shape exhale
lift your head neck and shoulders and
start to roll up like a ball pause using
your abs and then round the back rule
right back down and then right back up
pause there we're gonna take it into our
like little post teaser so start to
lengthen the legs lengthen the arms pull
the ABS in keep breathing
tuck and roll up like a snake squeeze
your booty at the top and then inhale
roll right back down like a snake